[Musique]
cachée par la forêt l'abbaye de fontenay
sa fontaine son cloître et sa source
l'un des huit joyau de la région classée
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
900 ans qu'elle fait la fierté des
habitants de marmagne
on a énormément de monde qui vient et il
faut absolument aller la voir
puisqu'elle est vraiment très très bien
entretenu c'est vraiment un lieu
magnifique
80 mille touristes s'y rendent chaque
année pour eux pas de doute l'abbaye
fait partie des plus beaux monuments
français c'est un endroit d'exception et
c'est magnifique c'est comment dire
c'est à la fois simple et dépouillée
mais voilà grandiose elle s'est vraiment
senti qu on a trouvé le cadre magnifique
très belle restauration la pierre en
plus c'est splendide avoir l'on
n'imagine les moines qui qui marche qui
prit qui travaille juste éblouissant
avec son style roman sobre fidèle à la
philosophie cistercienne senneff et sa
statue de la vierge marie léglise et de
lieux incontournables de l'abbaye la
règle du silence était évidemment
omniprésente ici et les moines n'a
n'était pas détourner de leurs prières
de leurs méditations
par des scènes de la bible qu'on aurait
pu trouver dans les chapiteaux ou dans
les vitraux cette houle inverse
le 17 septembre prochain l'abbaye
deviendra peut-être le monument préféré
des français de quoi écrire une nouvelle
page dans l'histoire de ce bijou presque
millénaire
[Musique]